it can be tempting at times of darkness
to seek advice from earlier generations
of world leaders
gracia michelle is a veteran advocate
for global peace women's rights and
humanitarian justice she was also at
various times wife of nelson mandela and
wife of samora michelle the president of
mozambique now as a deputy chair of the
elders she works alongside figures such
as jimmy carter mary robinson and ban
ki-moon
first up thank you so much uh for taking
some time to talk to us at sky news
today i just wanted to reflect with you
a bit on where we are in the world
there was a time i think when everything
felt positive at the turn of the century
your late husband nelson mandela was
free dictatorships were in retreat the
un millennium goals were about tackling
poverty and now i look around the world
and we have war in ukraine ethiopia
yemen and elsewhere humanitarian crises
authoritarian regimes global warning is
accelerating
from your point of view grass where did
it all go so wrong we have to recognize
that
most of the
crises
we are faced with today
are man-made
so
i believe it's mostly
a failure of leadership
if i want to give an example
the
climate change issue
oh
how many years we have been told
year after year
with unequivocal
statistics showing exactly how the
situation is getting out of control but
the leaders of the world they don't seem
to be listening
they don't seem to be taking the with
the same magnitude of the crisis
measures which would be
tackling and preventing the situation
where we are today going back to africa
there was optimism
about africa about development but
there's still conflict there's still
positive poverty
massive unfilled human potential why is
it taking so long again does it for you
go back to leadership not just
leadership within african nations but
also global leadership from other
leaders around the world is it back to
that again
definitely
because
why for instance a country like ethiopia
would be involved with itself
there's no other answer it's because
leaders are failing to one
to develop governments which will
involve everyone in the specific
countries to be in charge
second
they fail i mean to be inclusive
bringing
regions bringing different ages bringing
different skills to be part of the
decision making in their own countries
and of course
terrorism will use all the gaps which
exist i mean to flourish so it is not
drought it is no doubt an issue of
leadership
but you are asking about the world as
well and the climate change is a good
example of
failure
globally
how many times since copenhagen
the leaders of the world they pledged
to
give a hundred billion dollars every
year to tackle climate change but
particularly for mitigation adaptation
and supporting poor countries i mean who
did not make the climate change i mean
reach the levels in which we are and
they promise and promise every year and
nothing happens so you find failure of
leadership
within
africa yes but on climate change it's
mostly global because africa is paying
the price of
a situation it did not create
and
i believe we need we need to encourage
our young people and women i will insist
on women as well because they are most
imp impacted by this i mean to
take leadership to voice
what are the aspirations and to mobilize
so that we have
different kind of leadership which is
going to take into account the feelings
the aspirations the visions which are
coming from people themselves
and just finally there's been some
coverage recently about the commonwealth
uh with prince william
saying um that he won't necessarily head
the commonwealth he might not be head of
the commonwealth do you think an
organization like the commonwealth still
has any resonance uh with africans and
african nations
i think uh
any
kind of organization
which build the bridges
amongst peoples of the world amongst the
nations it's welcome
what i believe the
commonwealth should
do is
to perhaps to
revisit
the reasons why these nations
across the globe are coming together
not to be based on the past yes
but it to be based on
interest
of these nations
as part of the human family today and
tomorrow so
yes it is relevant but i think it needs
to reinvent itself to readjust to what
are the issues which would bring these
nations together congress i love the
idea of
building bridges between nations and
that the commonwealth can stand for that
like it can be nations with common
interests working together on issues
such as climate change but i guess the
question is do you think that the royal
family
of the united kingdom should head that
group of nations
well i will leave
i will live with the nations who are
part of the commonwealth to to to decide
that because i don't think it's a
personal opinion is my but
you have you seen what has happened
recently in the caribbean
do you follow what is it
what is the message which is coming from
thee and i think it's not against the
royal family it is mostly readjustment
of the kind of relationship in which
it's a relationship amongst the equals
within an organization
and
that is what i'm trying to say in my own
words of how
an organization can adjust itself
the the the the the uk
is is a country which
yes in the past had
a certain kind of a role in the world
but the uk today
has to recognize that democratic
institutions are the ones which are
prevailing and
how
does this happen i'm just suggesting
listen to what the caribbeans are saying
okay grassa it was an absolute pleasure
uh to talk to you thank you so much
and i love those roses on your jacket
they look absolutely gorgeous um thank
you so much for your time it was an
absolute honour to talk to you thank you
the wonderful grass and michelle there
well thank you to all our guests this
evening don't forget to download the
beth rigby interviews podcast for more
content